Ubisoft as it struggles after a string
of commercial misses internal
cancellations and delays doubles down on
arguably its biggest franchise Far Cry
and when I say double down I do mean
double with reportedly two games for
this series in the works one single
player the other multiplayer this is
according to an inside gaming report
that claims the unannounced Far Cry
titles were originally meant to be one
game until Dan hey the former franchise
executive director for Far Cry left
Ubisoft to work at Blizzard
Entertainment the report goes on to say
that the single player project is now
being referred to as project Blackbird
and the multiplayer Far Cry is being
called project Maverick with Ubisoft
Montreal being heavily involved in both
games although not much is known the
report suggests that the multiplayer
project Maverick will be set in the
Alaskan Wilderness and is said to be an
extraction-based looter shooter this
does align with the previous poll that
Ubisoft did in the past that was
originally spotted by PC Gamer where it
asked fans where they'd like to see the
next Far Cry be based one of the options
was Alaska traditionally most Far Cry
games have been single player focuses
with the option to play co-op if these
details turn out to be accurate this
situation sounds a lot like what
happened with The Last of Us Part 2
which initially was going to have a
multiplayer component that ultimately
got spun out into its own project with
more details on that to come later this
year as multiplayer games become
increasingly more Standalone in their
size and scope it'll be interesting to
see how many more games that would
traditionally combine their single and
multiplayer components begin to Splinter
them a game that shipped with both a
single and multiplayer mode was Dead
Space 2 the remake of its predecessor
just shipped and in the original dead
spaces remake players think they found
an Easter egg to indicate the sequel
will be getting the same treatment after
completing the game players have the
option to replay the story with new game
plus once they load back into the game
players will notice a few new text logs
that weren't originally there when they
first played it in the new logs players
can read an email like exchange between
two characters talking about looking for
new employment opportunities due to the
decommissioning that's supposed to
happen within the next year as the
conversation continues the two talk
about potentially working at the sprawl
on Titan this location is significant in
the Dead Space franchise because this is
the location where Isaac ends up
fighting for his life in Dead Space 2
after narrowly escaping the USG ishimura
with EA struggling to put out single
player games not a part of the Star Wars
franchise if Dead Space remake sells
well you've got to imagine that a remake
of the equally popular sequel would be
on the table just expect it to only ship
with single player with a dead space
multiplayer Standalone game releasing
down block then headspace remake
breathes life into a long dormant
franchise which is exactly what the
Lords of the Fallen will do when it
releases a sequel to the nearly decade
old souls like Lords of the Fallen
speaking with Edge magazine the
developer revealed a few key new details
about what players should expect from
the game the most interesting are how
the game's equivalent of bonfire's work
as well as what happens to the character
when they die the Lords of the fallen's
anchors will serve as the resting points
for the player where they can refill
health and items but also reset the
world and bring back previously
vanquished foes however anchors at fixed
locations will be sparse with the bulk
of anchors being craftable by the player
for them to place in locations of their
choosing when a player perishes they can
choose to revive at the closest anchor
and travel back to the location of their
death to pick up their XP like most
Souls likes or they have the option to
Traverse the umbral round a dark mirror
to the regular world in the game The
umbral Realm holds unique items that you
cannot find otherwise but healing items
are less effective and players will need
to seek out a totem if they wish to
leave if all that sounds intriguing to
you make sure to check out the full Dev
interview what do you think about the
idea of there being a standalone single
player and Standalone multiplayer Far
Cry game what do you think about Lords
of the fallen's changes to the
souls-like formula let us know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
foreign